no guys big bagman dick-sucker here with
another wacky zappy let's play
welcome back tomorrow makers guys well
bang hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Mario
maker I'm trying to find good levels and
not rage rule well okay alright then Wow
there we go then I can feel a little
accomplished about myself because I
solved that incredibly difficult level
there so welcome back to Mario maker I'm
gonna find more interesting levels and
then in the next episode if I do another
episode then I'll do some more difficult
ones and solve a very rayji level for
you all in one episode I won't even try
multiple times so I'm gonna find some
more creative ones here trying to find
like the top level creators but oddly
enough like most of the top creators
stampy
really stampylonghead most of the top
level creators that i've seen have been
Auto levels
I got silly silly swamp wrong that
sounds pretty cool
22% clear rate I can do that I can
manage with that clear rape it's meant
for little babies and that works
perfectly for me I murdered him oh yeah
that was horrible
i straight-up murdered him I didn't even
expect that he could die
bad I I get those going there you get a
spring here and then hop up a big hose
Waypoint I guess it's treads given
somehow I'm failing the level made for
tiny babies oh no no how do i there we
go yes okay oh let me get my rattle in
my bottle
I didn't actually expect that much water
was left in there I could have sworn
that was empty before hey took a swig of
that oopsies
oopsy poopsy z-- baby made a mess now
baby needs to go find another little
baby baby level to feed his little baby
baby ego remember I'm dick sucker Mick
know I'm close my name dick I'm dick
ugly I have no idea forget I said
anything
I'm curious if stampedes made some good
levels here I mean I've never even tried
my hand at seems bad oh god no wait wait
I'm doing this wrong that was fun
cheated with the checkpoint there unless
it like starts you with the appropriate
amount of time which I'm failing a dozen
is actually really how did someone do
that in six seconds what a load of bull
that's a bunch of lies if ever I saw one
that was lies all right that was pretty
cool that was really cool I like that a
lot
oh man got some good ones here all right
this is 15% I can do that I can do that
oh my god
world champion Mario maker Blair also
known as a Mario player maker doer
oh look a solvent problems with my boobs
god dammit
there I was tootin my own music and
didn't you know I got my just desserts
okay here I go toot in my own weasel
look at me I didn't get that dough god
I'm not getting the stars I'm so stupid
but wouldn't you know it I'm doing ok
with my life oh come on now these are
cool look I'm having a great time
playing these I mean hot damn okay let's
see what's this eight point eight for
Bowser boozled I'm gonna do the bean
boozled gym if you want me to do the
bean boozled challenge in the future
like comment and subscribe
actually I'm probably let me know if you
want to see the bean boozled challenge
that pork ooh that pork goopy dude I'm
like totally screwing myself over but
it's completely my fault like it's no
one's fault but my own
I'm skirting death I just run face first
into it that would be good okay so
there's got to be a way to get the
Bowser that's got to be the tricky
because if I take Koopa with me I should
be able to bounce up off it where I get
which is that people I think if I try
are I spin jump point maybe I gotta jump
from over there man I've got a problem
so if I I think if I take a running jump
from that moving
for me then I should be able to have
enough momentum to be able to get all
the way over but I gotta go now ish oh
oh and then the spin dnews I forgot
about the spinny news I can do this
video I'm gonna have a great time with
these is this what happens when people
actually make good levels that are
challenging but not terribly challenging
to the point where like you can get him
it's not the worst thing in the world oh
god I forgot that you can what yeah I
forgot that in the Super Mario me
there's a waffle dough which is like
oh no that's that's dead okay so I just
got it I just got to do it like quicker
that fireball that fireball is literally
right where I want to be but I'm damn it
I almost got you you Bowser [ __ ] I can
do this I can do this I know I can do
this
I've almost got the statuses god damnit
Bowser you Bulls are your BOSU ball
maybe fight maybe I don't need that
god dammit bozer bozer with your hose
and fine I'll do it with this
Oh poke my dupe
these are really fun
these are well-made well-designed Ricca
they got a unique Dookie due to it I
just needed more speed I didn't realize
I get it from the bottom there
oopsies my bad I probably could get it
just if I run straight over with me
being a big dumbass I didn't even think
to keep running oh well
choo choo goes home sounds like a sad
story am I gonna cry at the end of this
I mean I don't need an emotional time
for me I've been through a lot today
like how I jump blindly into these
levels without even trying to understand
what I'm supposed to be doing and then I
scoff at the idea that like I'm about to
die I can't believe I don't like
actually understand Oh what I did was
bad where are you taking me stampy are
you taking me thank you god damn it
well there goes all my oh I can go
through here because I'm an idiot and
didn't understand that well yes
I can I can lose it just quickly choo
choo go home
I was very scared very very scared
Firefly I can see how the finances up
I'm gonna do one more stampy's it's
really fun man I really hope that's
actually stampy I'm pretty sure my look
at that frou-frou Irish luck it's made
for jacksepticeye alright I'm gonna play
Irish luck I have a feeling this has
nothing to do with jacksepticeye but
that doesn't mean that I'm not going to
bleed Joe how you all suck so this is
gonna be a grab bag of random the other
thing that I was expecting oh I'm such
an idiot
goddammit why do I keep doing this to
myself such a goddamn fool such a
goddamn fool no god dammit god dammit
get there we go P stand for this
but myself over all those years of
abandoning Yoshi just to get to the
finish line as a child really paid off
okay so that's all for Mario maker today
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think of these
levels down in the comments below Thank
You stampy for making them this is this
is awesome I had a great time I am
really really happy right now because of
what I did so thank you everybody so
much for watching
and as always I will see you
in the next video